last time you were on the show you said
some girls shouldn't work yeah we we
talked about it a little bit
you got specific you said Miley Cyrus
shouldn't work well you know I'm not
ganging up on Molly's side now I just
think you should grow a little more I
have a lot more to work with before you
start to twerk you're not on me make it
a strong woman body yeah and before you
start to twerk right right right you got
to have nobody want to see you twerk to
start a fire you're not a man no all
right so okay you said that now you're
back and you have a you have a video
that came out music drop girl yeah and
in this video you seem to be working
with women who actually have something
to twerk yeah yeah they have some to
twerk oh yeah yeah yeah yeah let's take
a look a quick look at that video
[Music]
jobs in the top
[Music]
right now
[Applause]
that's perfect this you gotta have a
little giggle see when it's done
correctly there it's things moving in
every which direction at the same time
yeah you know you remember you was at
the video shoot remember yes it'll get
you off the video shoot yeah
remembered I kept calling and saying can
I come by today I hear doing we had to
actually physically take you off the set
okay let me ask you a question did you
cast the women that are in the twerking
video did you know
you did know damn well you was in there
I had my lady here to inspect the
twerking
you